we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p yesterday i
talked about the cult-like nature of
trumpets both a cult of personality
around trump but also the very cult-like
behavior of many of trumps followers
which includes always finding reasons
why the bad things that Trump does
aren't really bad ignoring information
about bad things that Donald Trump does
we talked about it all before I got a
voicemail yesterday from at rumpus who
says he is not pleased with me making
the cultist analogy take a listen to
this yeah I just watch your show will
you lambasted tucker carlson and i'm a
trump supporter and there are 62 million
of us or 60 million of us yeah and
you're really condescending and
insulting to us that we're not smart
enough to think on our own or how we're
gonna pay for something i mean it's
ridiculous the way you talk about us
that were a cult are you kidding me i
just melt no one's gonna put me in a
cult no politician is going to brainwash
me into voting for them yeah i mean you
know one of the things that's important
to understand about cults is nobody
who's in a cult thinks they're in a cult
until sometimes after they've left the
cult no one who is brainwashed believes
that they have been brainwashed because
knowing you've been brainwashed would be
an antidote to the brainwashing and the
reality is a lot of people who voted for
Trump are ignorant people i I've said
before there's ignorant people on all
sides of the political spectrum
if someone in an uninformed way votes
for a Democrat or a progressive or
whatever it's not any less informed than
an ignorant Republican voter I would be
glad if they end up making the right
decision but there's uninformed and
ignorant voters on both sides but as I
said before there are basically three
categories of people who voted for
Donald Trump and I know this pisses a
lot of people off there are ignorant
people right people who just didn't know
what they were voting
they didn't understand they were they
either fell for things Trump said that
were impossible and said this is why I'm
gonna vote for the guy without realizing
that the the the they were impossible
promises or they just don't pay
attention to politics ignorance to some
degree there are people who are
cognitively limited and that again I'm
not insulting anybody it's just there's
a lot of people in the electorate who
vote but they don't really have the
cognitive capacity to understand what is
going on it's not ignorance but it's a
limitation and then you have just what I
would call bad people and I know that
good bad is it's a very rudimentary and
unsophisticated way to categorize but
what I mean by bad people is it's not
people who are cognitively limited it's
not people who are ignorant to the facts
it's people who understand exactly what
it is that Donald Trump is promising and
they like it right they like it because
it's good for them personally because of
taxes for example or whatever those are
the three categories I've still not met
anyone to this day who voted for Trump
who doesn't fall into one of those three
categories and I will completely concede
to you that there are people on the left
at least with two of those three
categories that we could identify as
well prove me wrong I'm open to having
my mind changed we've got a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
the repositioning of coalition forces
thanks to Donald Trump see Ron
belligerents we will talk about CNBC
using the wrong pictures on screen for
presidential candidates Andrew yang and
Tulsi Gabbard and we will also talk
about kids who have been shot after
throwing snowballs at passing cars this
reminds me of something former producer
Louis and I used to do all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
get instant access by signing up at join
pakman.com I'll speak to you that